>> HE IS NOT ONLY A BUMBLING
IDIOT, HE IS A BUMBLING LIAR.
>> Laura: HAD BETTER BE A LOT
OF MONEY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ADAM SCHIFF IS ACCUSING A FORMER
PRESIDENTIAL ADVISER OF LYING.
HE IS A RANKING DAM ON THE INTEL
HOUSE COMMITTEE.
YOU SEE THEM ON CABLE NEWS, BUT
NOT THE SHOW.
THE COMMITTEE LAST SEPTEMBER
CONFLICTED WITH THE ESTABLISHED
FACTS.
HERE TO RESPOND IS ROGER STONE.
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK, I HAVE
IT IN MY LIVING ROOM, "STONE
RULES" AND IT IS HILARIOUS.
YOU ARE APPARENTLY A LIAR SAYS
ADAM SCHIFF.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE IN YOUR
CRYING TOWEL ALL DAY AND NIGHT.
>> I HATE TO SAY IT, BUT IT IS
MORE [BLEEP] FROM THE
CONGRESSMAN OF CALIFORNIA.
IF HE IS REFERRING TO THE
TWITTER DIRECT MESSAGES WHICH
WERE LEAKED TO THE ATLANTIC, A
PROOF THAT I HAD NO
COLLABORATION WITH WIKILEAKS.
I TURN THOSE OVER TO THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE LAST
SEPTEMBER.
IF HE IS REFERRING TO THE EMAILS
THAT WERE CITED BY
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" THAT
PROVED THAT I HAD NO DIRECT
CONTACT FROM THE SOURCE AND WAS
USING A BACK CHANNEL, WHY THOSE
FELL OUT THE PRECISELY WORDED
SCOPE OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEES REQUEST.
A SCOPE COSIGNED BY MR. SCHIFF
HIMSELF.
THE REAL ISSUE, LAURA, VERY
CLEAR.
HE HAS SAID THAT HE HAS SEEN
"SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF RUSSIA
COLLUSION IN THE 2016 ELECTION"
AND HAS PRODUCED NONE, ZERO.
HE WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE THE
SUBJECT.
MY TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE WAS
ENTIRELY TRUTHFUL.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT HE
SAID, HE SAID THAT TESTIMONY OF
DON JR., AND OTHERS IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE REPORTS OF
MEETINGS, CONVERSATIONS AND
OTHER FACTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND TO THE PUBLIC
REPORTS ARE ACCURATE, THEN
CLEARLY THEY WERE NOT TELLING
THE TRUTH.
DON'T YOU LOVE HOW HE WORDS IT?
IF THE PUBLIC REPORTS ARE --
WELL, AGAIN.
I THINK THAT THEY NOW, ROGER
KNOW THAT THERE IS NO THERE
THERE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CAP IT INTO
CARTER PAGE AND HE HAS SEEN HIS
FORTUNES GO DOWN THERE TOO
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THIS.
FIGHTING IN COURT, THEY HAVE ALL
OF THE CONVICTIONS OF THE
FIGURES EXCEPT FOR THE DEAL WITH
PAUL MANAFORT.
WE WILL SEE WHERE THAT GOES IN
HIS ASSOCIATES.
BUT I THINK THAT THEY ARE COMING
UP EMPTY.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP IT IN THE
PRESS SOMEHOW.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP IT GOING
SOMEHOW WITH THE LITTLE SPARKS
OF SUPPOSE THAT INTEREST.
BUT I DO NOT THINK THAT IT
WORKS.
>> YOU MAY REMEMBER, LAURA, I
WANTED HIM TO TESTIFY IN PUBLIC
IN A PUBLIC HEARING SO THAT
EVERYBODY COULD SEE IT.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TESTIFY FOR
THAT INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ON
THE SENATE SIDE.
AND I REQUEST THAT THAT IS IN
PUBLIC, LET THE TV CAMERAS ROLL.
>> Laura: YOU JUST WANT TO
SELL YOUR BOOK, ROGER.
LET'S BE HONEST.
WHAT IS POSSIBLY GOING TO BE
INVOLVED.
I THINK THAT THEY KNOW, THEY
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE COME UP WITH
GOOSE EGGS AND THEY DO NOT WANT
TO BE HUMILIATED.
YOU CANNOT GET BETWEEN THEM AND
A CAMERA USUALLY.
BECAUSE IF THEY DO NOT WANTED TO
BE ON CAMERA, IT IS NOT BECAUSE
OF CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
ALSO WANTING TO TESTIFY, HE SAID
THAT HE WOULD TESTIFY, DID NOT
CLAIM THAT HE WANTED IMMUNITY,
HE WANTED TO DO IT IN PUBLIC.
THE BILLIONAIRE WHO THEY TRIED
TO GET ROPED INTO THE COLLUSION
THINK THAT HE SAID, YOU ARE
RIDICULOUS.
AND THEY WOULD NOT HAVE HIM
TESTIFY.
THEY HAVE NOT BROUGHT THE
RUSSIAN LAWYER IN, BUT SHE SAID
I'M HAPPY TO COME.
THEY WILL NOT TALK TO HER.
EITHER THE KEY FIGURES LIKE THIS
LAWYER, WHY WOULD THEY NOT BRING
THE RUSSIAN LAWYER IN, IT IS
CURIOUS.
>> COMING UP EMPTY-HANDED WITH
ANY EVIDENCE OF RUSSIA
COLLUSION, AND EMPTY HANDED OF
ANY HIJINKS REGARDING ALLEGEDLY
HACKED EMAILS WITH WIKILEAKS,
NOW THEY WANT TO CONCOCT SOME
NEW CRIME, OR NEW OFFENSE IN AN
ATTEMPT TO GET ME TO TESTIFY
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS NOT ONLY RIDICULOUS, BUT
IT IS VERY EXPENSIVE, LAURA.
THIS THREATENS TO BANKRUPT MY
FAMILY.
I'VE HAD TO SET UP STONE DEFENSE
FUND.COM, BECAUSE I CAN NO
LONGER BEAR THE LEGAL EXPENSES.
>> Laura: THAT IS WHAT THEY
DO, DON'T THEY.
THEY TURN THE SCREWS ON PEOPLE
THEY SAY WILL ULTIMATELY DESTROY
YOUR FAMILY AND NOT SO MANY
WORDS.
AND THEN THEY GET THESE
LOW-LEVEL FIGURES AND SAY, OKAY,
STOP, I WILL TELL YOU WHATEVER I
WANT.
IF I HAVE TO SAY IT THEN THEY
GET 1,001 CONVICTION AND THEN A
PLEA AND THEN IT IS OVER.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.